so we're here at the Bud Light house
party when's the last time you into an
epic house party probably New Year's Eve
but I do go to a lot of house parties
they're one of my like favorite places
to existence oh so what do you love
about them um great music great friends
a genuine sense of like being free when
you party you know there's no rules at
our house party so do you have time to
go to a lot of house parties because I
feel like you're really busy these days
no I do yeah I do I throw them as well
right I throw a really good house party
okay so what makes a good house party
like what do you what are your staple
things um just people you love yeah
that's really important really good DJ
DJ but you don't want somebody who's
gonna be too indulgent with the songs
but I got a crowd please when you're
doing like a house party you know and
then yeah just just like good energy
good vibe good drinks I'm gonna say
drinks very good yeah
you know good stuff so I want to talk
about the Brit Awards they're coming up
which is really exciting even nominate a
female solo artist of the year what does
that feel like it's quite surreal yeah
it's very I'm honored to be nominated
especially alongside all of the other
artists who are who are in the category
alongside me and yeah you know I've been
in music now like professionally for 11
years so I feel ya just happy to finally
have been like invited along to the
party you posted on social media you
know what it means for you to be
nominated but also give a shout out to
the epic women you're nominated with why
is it important for you to support other
women in this industry you know I think
being a woman in any industry it's
always hard you know women are
constantly doubted constantly pitted
against each other
constantly there is this kind of almost
like desire for for women to fail so I
think it's really important to support
one another in whatever way that you can
no matter what field you're in because
sometimes it feels like the world
doesn't want women to succeed and
luckily that narrative is changing but
it takes you know constant conversation
and constant support from your fellow
females to really make sure that change
does happen let's talk about your most
recent album Charlie mm-hmm you did some
amazing collaborations on there can we
please talk about your collaboration
with Liz oh yeah she's awesome I mean
she is like exactly who you think she is
you know
yeah she's she's really great and you
know we've known each other for a while
and to kind of get in the studio with
her and write was just a really fun
experience because like me she's very
quick when she writes so it's really fun
to just see her be like in her element
and flow out these ideas in such a
natural way
how are you so quick is it have you just
always been that way did the ideas come
and it just got other things to do and
I'm gonna bang it out no I don't know I
just find that it's good to just be
really spontaneous when you write
because I think that's how the real
emotion comes out the second I start
thinking about lyrics or overthinking
lyrics they become almost fake you know
I like the kind of the first thing that
comes to my head
it makes it more authentic that way I
suppose yeah so we were talking about
Liz oh I mean she did such a great job
with the Grammys and of course you know
she cleaned up and so did Billy Eilish
would you ever consider doing
collaboration with Billy Eilish I mean
Billy's an incredible artist and I'm
really inspired by all artists who are
you know truly unique and truly do their
own thing you know don't follow trends
and and don't really you know
or mold themselves into what other
people wanted that want them to be and
that's why I collaborated with all of
the people I did on my record and that's
why I admire artists like Billy you know
she's she's so uniquely herself
you wrote senorita for Camila caballo
and Shawn Mendes did you know while
you're writing it that that song was
gonna be that big of a hit well when I
found out that they were involved in it
yes because you know they're two of the
biggest artists in the world and yeah I
co-wrote I mean that they are both great
writers as well actually and they had a
hand in making this song that's you know
but yeah I kind of when I heard it was
gonna come out I was like cool I was
like cool I can do some weird stuff with
my career now I can just do whatever I
want which is great I kind of give a bit
of freedom then definitely what you can
do
oh sure yeah yeah do you have for eight
songs they become huge hits and then
you're like oh I wish I saying that one
um no I think for me singing senorita
would be a bit of a fail obviously yeah
it's just you know it's not my it's not
it's not I couldn't carry it yeah I
couldn't pull it off the way they do and
obviously I'm I don't have that like
crazy high profile chemistry popstar
relationship that they do so yeah I
don't think it would have been as
successful but yeah there are songs I've
written in the past one in particular
actually one called the same old love
which I wrote with Selena Gomez which I
was like that was the closest where I
was like should I keep this but actually
the second that I heard her version I
was like no pretty neat belongs with you
and it felt really real um you are a
songwriter you're an artist you're
businesswoman you are a role model to so
many of your fans how did that feel
feels stressful like you they feel like
a pressure on well yeah
because I didn't get into music to
become a role model but obviously I
understand that it comes with the
territory
and you know I think that wherever
possible I always try and encourage my
fans or people who follow me to be
themselves just as I am you know I am
myself and I'm a human who makes
mistakes and I think that's one thing I
you know hope that they take away from
me as an artist as that humans make
mistakes and that's ok and I think there
needs to be yeah a level of life
forgiveness and in life that I feel like
sometimes doesn't really exist anymore
how would you describe your life right
now jet-lagged oh yeah that's how I
would describe it I was in Australia
like three days ago and then yesterday I
was in the UK yeah and today I'm here
and tomorrow I'm gonna be in the UK
again okay so how do you maintain your
level of energy because you perform so
you're you know you're on coffee coffee
and just adrenaline and I don't really
know I don't really know
do you ever crash after where you're
like I need no one to talk to me for a
week um you know what I somehow managed
to level out a little bit and and and
it'd be okay
so generally I find if I take too much
like time off I go a little bit crazy